less than 0.2 percent of covid19
vaccines administered globally have gone
to low-income countries
meps were divided over whether
intellectual property rights on covid19
vaccines should be waived
some called instead for vaccine
production to be ramped up and export
barriers lifted
parliament approved the 28 billion euro
erasmus plus program
it will be more inclusive than ever
improving access to learning
for people living in poverty with a
disability or coming from a migrant
background
meps adopted a 17.5 billion euro package
to help finance the transition to a
greener economy
the just transition fund supports people
upskilling
re-skilling and changing jobs in regions
likely to be most affected by new
climate rules
the last two weeks have seen the worst
violence between israelis and
palestinians in years
israel has carried out numerous
airstrikes on gaza
and hamas has fired rockets into israel
meps called for an immediate ceasefire
and stressed the need for dialogue
a 2020 global witness report said that
across the world
212 environmental defenders were killed
in 2019
meps urged the eu to do more to protect
climate activists
defending their land and communities and
called for ecocide
to be recognised as an international
[Music]
crime